Transcriber: gaith Takrity
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
مرحبًا، أنا سعاد.
وأريد أن أشارككم بعض المقتنيات
من صندوقي الخاص،
طفولة مقموعة، تنمر، قيود مجتمعية،
وزواج مبكر وأمومة مبكّرة.
خلافات، صراعات، قيود وطلاق،
مرض وسرطان؛
إبر وكيماوي ووفاة وفقدان.
والكثير من الأشياء؛
هناك أشياء أتذكرها وأشياء لا أتذكرها
لأن عقلنا اللاواعي يخزن أحيانًا أحداثًا،
وصدمات في باطن الصندوق
لكي يحمينا من آلامها.
لكن في كل الأحوال،
سواء تذكرت الأحداث أم لا،
فهي تسيطر على مشاعرك وقراراتك
وتوجهاتك في الحياة.
لن أتكلم عن تفاصيل الصندوق،
أتيت لأشارككم وصفتي؛
الأدوات التي استخدمتها
لأتجاوز مقتنيات  الصندوق
ليس فقط تقبّل هذا الصندوق وتسخيره لمصلحتي،
والوصول إلى هنا لأشارككم هذه الأدوات .
الأداة الأولى، وهي التسليم،
والتسليم لا يعني الاستسلام.
التسليم بمعنى أن تسلّم
أن هناك خالق لهذا الكون،
ولنظام الكون الذي يسخّر كل شيء موجود
في هذا الكون لمصلحتك
لتستطيع أن توصل رسالتك
التي خُلقت من أجلها.
التسليم هو أن تؤمن أن أي حَدَث يحصل معك،
سلبي أو إيجابي،
هو موجود لتصحيح مسار وفيه دائمًا مصلحة لك.
في كل صدمه وفي كل أزمة، هناك هدية،
هناك كنز بالداخل إذا قررت معرفته.
يقول هايكو آرنست، وهو مدير
مجلة علم النفس الألمانية اليوم،
أنه بعد دراسات عديدة، وجدوا أن هناك
صلة وثيقة وقوية وإيجابية بين الإيمان
وبين قدرتك على مواجهة هذه الصدمات.
يعني بين الإيمان والتسليم
وحالتك الصحية والنفسية،
يعني كلما كان عندك تسليم
وإيمان بوجود خالق،
وأنه يوجد حكمة في كل حدث هي لمصلحتك،
فأنت تكون قادرًا على حل هذه المشكلة،
وتكون أقل عرضة
للصدمات النفسية والاضطرابات،
وأكثر قدرة على القبول و التأقلم.
من أجل ذلك، هناك أشخاص تختار
أن ترفض الحَدَث وتبقى فيه،
وأشخاص يختارون تقبّله والتسليم به.
يقول ديفيد هوكينز،
وهو المعلم الأول في التنوير
وطبيب صوفي تكّرم في جميع أنحاء العالم،
في كتابه السماح بالرحيل:
“كل حَدَث أنت تقاومه تسمح له
أن يتواجد في حياتك أكثر،
وكل شعور تهاجمه، يعود لعقلك بشراسة أكبر.
كل حَدَث تحاول أن ترفضه
يدافع عن نفسه ويقاومك،
لهذا تقبّله فيذهب بسلام وتسمح له بالرحيل“.
ولنا في الطبيعة عبرة،
هل رأيتم شجرة تبكي لأن - أوراقها سقطت؟
لا، هي تعلم يقينًا أنها سوف تزهر من جديد.
الأداة الثانية، وهي فن تغيير المعنى .
لو أنا الآن دخلت إلى المسرح ووقعت،
كيف ستكون ردة فعلي؟
سأضحك وأقوم أنفضُ ملابسي،
وأقول لكم حصل خير وهيا بنا نكمل خطابنا.
في المقابل، يمكن لشخص آخر إذا وقع
على المسرح أن يغضب ويكسّر ويتحرك دون وعي
و يشتم المسرح والساعة التي آتى بها
إلى المسرح ويخرج غاضبًا ولا يكمل الخطاب.
الحَدَث واحد، ولكن ردة الفعل هي المختلفة.
و المسؤول عن ردود أفعالنا
هو المفهوم الذي نعطيه للحَدَث،
فالمعنى الذي أعطيته للحدث،
كوّن عندك الفكرة  ثم الشعور
ثم السلوك الذي هو ردة الفعل.
فتستطيع أن تختار العيش بعقلية الضحية
في كل حَدَث يحصل معك،
وتبكي وتندب حظك وتبقى في نفس الدائرة
أو تقرر استخلاص الحكمة والدروس
من هذا الحَدُث والمضي قدمًا وتجاوزه.
(تصفيق)
أتذكر جيدّا حينما كنت في الطابق الخامس
من المستشفى في قسم السرطان،
عندما كنت أمام لجنة طبية مكونة
من أساتذة متخصصين في الأورام،
وقال لي الدكتور رئيس اللجنة ببساطة،
لدى ابنك ذي الأربع سنوات ورم نادر
لا يمكن شفاؤه، يحتاج إلى معجزة إلهية.
لن يعيش أكثر من خمس سنوات
يا سعاد، آسفة خمسة شهور،
خمسة شهور.
انهار العالم وتهشمت روحي وتوقفت الحياة.
ولكن لا يوجد وقت معي، فالمتبقي خمسة شهور،
فما الذي يمكنني عمله؟
فأنا أمام خيارين؛
إما أن أختار إعطاء معنى سلبي
وأنهار مع الولد بفترة الخمسة شهور هذه،
ولا أساعده على مقاومة المرض،
أو أختار إعطاء معنى آخر إيجابي، وقد كان.
اخترت محاربة المرض مع ابني،
وأن أجعله يعيش أحلى أيام حياته
إن كانت خمسة شهور أو أكثر.
وأنه هدية من الله،
هذه هدية أعطاني إياها، وبالتأكيد
لأنني مسلمة لأمره، هناك حكمة منها.
بعد سنتين،
عندما وصلت إلى المستشفى
وابني على يدي ميت في سيارة الإسعاف.
استقبلتني الدكتورة الأستاذة المسؤولة
عن حالته على باب المستشفى،
وقالت لي سعاد لا تحزني،
كان من المفترض أن يعيش ابنك خمسة شهور،
لكنه عاش سنتين لأنك امرأة قوية.
(تصفيق)
لأنك امرأة حاربتِ ليعيش أحلى أيام
يمكن أن يعيشها طفل،
ولأنك كنت ملتزمة ومؤمنة بنفسك وبهذا الطفل.
أعترف، مؤلم الفقدان.
لكن هذه التجربة؛
جعلتني أرى النور الذي بداخلي
وأرى نقاط ضعفي وأعمل عليها.
أتمسك بالحياة وأحبها،
وأتمسك بأحلامي وببناتي المتبقيات.
و أصبح أكثر تهذيبًا ونضجًا وإنسانية.
(تصفيق)
الأداة الثالثة، وهي حب الذات.
ولا تصدقوا فكرة أن الذي يحب نفسه أناني،
لا تقبلوا هذه الفكرة.
الأناني هو إنسان ناقص  ولا يحب نفسه،
ينظر دومًا على ما يملكه الآخرين
ويريد كل شيء لنفسه،
لا يحب أن يعطي ولا يقتنع بشيء.
ولكن الذي يحب نفسه هو إنسان
لا يقارن نفسه بالآخرين.
راضٍ بما عنده وخزائنه ممتلئة،
ويحب نقاط قوته ويستثمرها دائمًا.
ويعمل على نقاط ضعفه.
ولأنه يحب ذاته، فإنه يضع لنفسه حدودًا،
لا يسمح لأحد أن يستغلها أو يؤذيها.
وبالتالي يرتقي دومًا بنفسه
من تعليم واهتمام واحترام.
يقول الدكتور فيل ماكرو، المحاور الشهير،
في كتابه الذي كتبه للنساء،
رسالة في كتاب “الحب ذكاء“، يقول لكل امرأة:
“إذا اعتقدتِ بأنك بضاعة مهملة،
سيصدق الجميع ذلك،
ويعاملونِك إزاء نظرتِك لنفسك،
عليكِ أن تقعي في غرام نفسك أولًا“.
(تصفيق)
والذي يجب نفسه، فالخبر السار أيضًا،
من المستحيل أن يؤذي الآخرين،
لأنه ببساطة، كلما كان واعيًا ...
والوعي مرتبط بحب الذات،
كلما كنت واعيًا، تحب ذاتك أكثر.
كلما أحببت ذاتك أكثر لن تؤذي أحدًا،
لأن إيذاء الآخرين، وأنت تعلم معنى ذلك،
سيعود عليك بنفس الأذى.
ولأنك لا تريد إيذاء نفسك، وتريد المحافظة
على كرامتها ووجودها وترتقي وتستثمر فيها،
فلن تؤذي أي مخلوق على الأرض،
وبالتالي فأنت إنسان صالح لنفسك وللآخرين.
وهذا دعوة وسؤال بشأن كل تصرفاتنا
في الحياة التي عشناها.
هل سألتم أنفسكم ذات مرة،
هل أنا أحب نفسي بشكل كافٍ؟
الأداة الرابعة، وهي التفريغ العاطفي،
والتفريغ العاطفي هو التنفيس؛
التنفيس عن مشاعرك ومكنوناتك الداخلية،
وإطلاق العنان لكل شعور تشعر به
ومشاركته بطريقة أو بأخرى.
عكس الكبت الذي صنفه فرويد؛
كبت واعي وكبت غير واعٍ،
بمعنى أنك تقرر الكبت وعدم مشاركة  الموضوع
وهذه المشاعر لأنك تخاف من نظرة المجتمع لك.
ومن المحتمل أن يكون عندك كما قلنا سابقًا
مشاعر مكبوتة لا تدركها
وتتحكم في توجهاتك وقراراتك
وحياتك و نظرتك لنفسك.
وبعد دراسات كثيرة بشأن الكبت،
تؤكد أن الكبت يسبب اضطرابات
وأمراض نفسية وجسدية أيضًا.
عكس التفريغ تمامًا الذي من الضروري
أن يصبح نمط حياة بالنسبة إلينا،
نعطي أنفسنا هذه المساحة ونعبر عن أنفسنا؛
بالتنفس أو التأمل،
أو القيام برحلات أو مشاركة مختص
أو صديق أو بالكتابة.
وبالمناسبه، كانت الكتابة
رفيقتي من عمر 12 سنة.
الكتابه التعبيرية هي تقنية اكتشفها
العالِم الأمريكي جيمس بينبيكر في عام 1986،
عندما أجرى دراسه مدتها ستة شهور
على مجموعة من الطلاب،
حيث طلب منهم ان يكتبوا كل يوم
ماذا يحدث معهم وما هي مشاعرهم.
ماذا تعتقدون أنه استنتج
أو اكتشف بعد ستة شهور؟
اكتشف أن هؤلاء الطلاب أصبحوا أكثر هدوءًا،
وأكثر قدرة على أن يسيطروا
على انفعالاتهم وأعصابهم،
وازدادت قدراتهم الأكاديمية.
واكتشف كذلك أن الكتابة
تسمح لمرضى السرطان أن يتحسنوا،
كما تشفي الصداع النصفي والروماتيزم
واضطرابات النوم والأكل أيضًا.
لهذا السبب،
تقول هذه الوصفة السحرية أنك اذا مارستها
لمدة ستة شهور أو أكثر،
فإنك ستحصل على حياة أكثر هدوءًا وإنتاجية.
وأنا شخصيًا هذه أداتي الخاصة بي.
كل واحد فيكم يسأل نفسه عن أكثر أداه
تبعث الراحة لنفسه وتعبر عن مشاعره حقًا.
(تصفيق)
الأداة الخامسة والأخيرة، وهي التدرج،
لدى معظمنا أحلام كبيرة،
لكن عندما نرى النتائج، نخاف الاقتراب
لأن صورة أحلامنا كبيرة، فنبتعد عنها.
أنا أضمن لكم أن هذه الطريقة
هي طريقة سحرية لتصلوا الى أحلامكم بسهوله.
وهي طريقة تتطلب التدرّج فيها.
وبخطوات صغيرة جدًا جدًا
تستطيع الوصول إلى حلمك
دون النظر إلى الناتج الكبير.
حاول كل يوم أن تاخد خطوة تقربك من الهدف،
إذا أردت تعلّم لغة، أدرس خمس كلمات يوميًا.
وإذا أردت فتح مشروع، ادرس دورة من هنا،
واجمع قليلًا من النقود
وكوّن علاقات من هنا.
هذه الأشياء البسيطة التي تعتقدون
أنها بسيطة جدًا وصغيرة وغير مؤثرة
هي التي ستصنع هذا الحلم الكبير بعد سنوات.
عندي ثلاثة إصدارات من الكتب
ومجموعة مقالات وقصص،
لم أكن أحتسي القهوة على الشرفة وأنا أكتب،
ولم أكن أسهر الليالي لأنهي الكتاب.
كنتُ أكتب نصًا كل يوم،
أو كل يوم أو يومين أكتب نصف صفحة
وفي آخر العام أرى مادة دسمة قابلة للنشر.
وهكذا أصدرت كتبي، وهكذا يستطيع أي أحد فيكم
أن يصل إلى حلمه وأن يحل مشكلته.
لو عندك مشكلة كبيرة جدًا
تدرّج في حلها أيضًا،
وسر بهذا المسار، فإنك ستتشافى وستتجاوزها،
وبخطوات صغيره ستصل إلى الحلم الكبير.
(تصفيق)
هذه الأدوات التي استخدمتها،
وأعدكم إذا استخدمتموها ستتغير حياتكم.
وساعدتني  أيضًا أن أضيف
إلى هذا الصندوق أشياء جديدة؛
شهادات عليا ودورات ومساقات وسياحة وسفر،
عائلة داعمة وأصدقاء رائعين.
ثلاثة كتب وإصدارات وروايات ومهرجانات
ومسارح وتكريم واليوم أنا في TEDx.
وحلمي ...
(تصفيق)
وحلمي أن أساعد أكبر شريحة من الناس
بتطوير مهاراتي العلاجية
وذلك لأفتح أكبر مركز حيث أساعد كل أحد
مرّ بأزمات أو فقدان أو صدمات
حتى يتقبل ماضيه ويعمل على حاضره
ويصنع مستقبله ليكون أفضل نسخة منه.
وشكرًا.
(تصفيق)